uh then he got into it with fox news's
peter ducey who is a
true journalist that we again we really
have we tried to get him on the show i
think we keep we keep yeah we got to try
we've got to get this guy on the show uh
i don't know that he does interviews
that but he's he's just doing a bang-up
job of holding this administration to
something like there's one guy trying to
do it
and here he is going after biden and
biden once again saying he didn't say
the thing that he said and we all heard
him say it are you worried that other
leaders in the world are going to start
to doubt that america is back if some of
these big things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what can he walk back it made it sound
like just in the last couple days uh it
sounded like you told us troops they
were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about helping train the
troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context i sat there with those guys
for a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with
beating with and talking with the uh
ukrainian troops who are in poland and
when you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in time
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you why would i
tell you you've got to be silly
the world wants to know the world wants
to know a lot of things i'm not telling
them what the response would be then
russia knows the response
okay so he did and i try to give him
credit when he's roughly
coherent and everything else at the end
there it's he said what i just said
earlier which is that you don't just
tell the enemy what you're going to do
when you're in war you don't just like
just put it all out there guys if you do
this then we do this if this happens
then this happens if this then this you
don't do that so i i will give him some
room to work there now the problem here
is that he partly not only does he just
muddle through all these things and then
say these things and then his people
have to apologize and the media runs
cover but he also kind of doesn't know
what he's saying so peter ducey asked
the right question there especially
about the troops he said to our troops
troops what you are going to see when
you are there and you're going to see
when you're there and if somehow you've
been there you're going to see you're
going to see women
young people standing standing in the
middle of the front of a damn tank
now he's backtracking and saying oh no
what i meant was i was talking to our
u.s troops who will be training
ukrainian troops in poland or something
like that and it's like i don't know
maybe that actually is what he meant
maybe he doesn't even know exactly what
he said
who the hell knows the point is that to
believe any of this at this point is is
tough let's say at best it is tough and
uh if if i haven't laid out a case for
you
now we're going to really slam the door
on this freaking thing because let's
talk about sanctions again you may
remember at the beginning of this whole
war this slow motion war that's going on
where remember for weeks at first they
kept saying putin's going to do it he's
on his way some stuff's going to happen
we'll see what we're going to do and you
know how can we figure out how to deter
him and it's a whole big thing right
we're going to see what we can do and
sanctions and deterrents and blah blah
blah
here's a spectacular compilation
of the confusion over what sanctions do
and why we would drop sanctions on
russia and you tell me i don't want to
color your opinion on this you tell me
if the messaging from this
administration makes any sense sanctions
never deter
you keep talking about that purpose of
the sanctions has always been and
continues to be deterrence the purpose
of the sanctions in the first instance
is to try to deter russia from going to
war the president believes that
sanctions are intended to deter they're
meant to prevent and deter a large-scale
invasion we want them to have a
deterrent effect the sanctions are
designed in the first instance to try to
deter russia for taking further
aggression as well as our efforts to uh
both try to deter russia through
sanctions if you pull the trigger on
that deterrent well then it doesn't
exist anymore as a deterrent
joe those are all people who work for
you
are they all liars or idiots